on passe maintenant à un autre événement
le printemps du commerce avec Dominique
Duguet le soir présidente de l'Union
commerciale des Clayes-sous-Bois
alors cet événement donc a commencé le
21 mai il se poursuit jusqu'au 2 juin
oui de quoi s'agit-il concrètement alors
en fait il s'agit de communiquer autour
du commerce de proximité donc on va
faire gagner des clients des cadeaux à
des clients pardon et
d'une façon très accueillante ils vont
ils vont venir on va leur donner des
tickets gagnants à gratter en fait il
prend gagner deux façons au grattage et
au tirage donc au grattage il gagne
immédiatement donc le commerçant offre
le cadeau aux clients il est mis en
valeur directement puisque c'est
lui-même qui offre le cadeau et
au tirage il gagne une trottinette
électrique donc en fait il y a 32 villes
qui participent et il y a 32
trottinettes électriques à gagner il y a
3500 commerçants
effectivement c'est un événement
organisé par la Chambre de commerce de
distribution mais également on parle
réseau des présidents d'union
commerciale c'était vraiment une
collaboration ça fait c'est la deuxième
édition donc en fait on a travaillé
pendant un an pour monter cette
opération on se réunit régulièrement à
la Chambre de commerce avec une
animatrice de réseau et nous avons monté
cette opération quand vous dites vous
vous réunissez vous parlez des unions
commerciales tout à fait tout est
président des unions commerciales
qu'est-ce qu'une union commerciale alors
une union commerciale c'est une
association qui rassemble des
commerçants en fait le commerçant c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui était assez
individualiste qui est assez seul dans
son métier et donc on fait on organise
des associations pour pouvoir pour que
les commerçants se retrouvent et puis se
discuter et animer leur commerce et leur
centre-ville donc finalement être plus
fort ensemble se faire connaître faire
connaître notre savoir-faire on a quand
même des atouts importants comme
l'accueil le conseil le service donc il
est important de faire connaître ça à
nos clients et il est également
important que ça soit une association
fédératrice
deux adhérents nous avons 52 adhérents
on est assez fier de ça parce que il y a
80 commerçants sur les clés pour donner
un exemple dans votre ville qu'est-ce
que vous organisez alors nous avons une
opération fête des mères nous avons une
opération nous venons juste de la
terminer qui est il était une fois les
clés en fait c'était un jeu pour les
clients où il devait retrouver les
nouveaux commerçants sur de très
vieilles photos en fait donc ça a
énormément plu parce que ça concernait
autant les personnes d'un certain âge
que les jeunes au travers des écoles et
au travers
des différents commerces alors vous
faites également partie donc d'un réseau
en début d'émission ce réseau finalement
ça regroupe plusieurs unions
commerciales le but c'est d'avoir une
encore plus grande visibilité tout à
fait en fait là nous avons nous sommes
44 à participer au réseau des présidents
de l'Union commerciale et donc c'est
pour vraiment se faire connaître le plus
possible également échanger parce que
chaque union commerciale est
indépendante mais il est important
d'échanger nos expériences nos
animations pour trouver toujours de
nouvelles idées pour nos villes vous
réunissez donc deux fois par mois deux
fois par mois donc lors de ces réunions
donc il y a les périodes d'échange ou
justement ce que je vous disais en
échange sur les animations mais il y a
également des intervenants la Chambre de
commerce nous fait venir des
intervenants sur des sujets comme
l'accessibilité aux personnes
handicapées dans les commerces puisque
ça va être une loi qui va passer enfin
qui va être appliqué très prochainement
c'est également
sur l'éclairage des vitrines pareil la
loi vient de changer il y a pas très
longtemps donc on a des consultants
régulièrement qui viennent nous parler
de nos droits de nos obligations en tant
que commerçant et que nous commercial
alors vous nous parlez donc de défense
de commerce de proximité est-ce que dans
les Yvelines vous souffrez de la
concurrence des centres commerciaux
notamment Clayes-sous-Bois il y en a
beaucoup nous sommes gâtés donc c'est
pas la même chose je pense qu'on peut
pas
au 10 juin pour permettre donc de
nouvelles propositions de repreneurs
depuis que la chaîne rougit épelée s'est
retirée le 17 mai il reste comme
repreneur potentiel la chaîne de
prêt-à-porter de chaussures Vivarte donc
il y a entre autres André la halle
Minelli elle s'intéresse à 10 magasins
sur les 26 et garderai 173 postes reste
également culturel qui visent deux
magasins Zara un seul et la foncière
Unibail A4 aucune annonce cependant n'a
été
soumise pour pour le Virgin de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le Bretonneux
la fin donc d'une époque le non Verdine
qui va disparaître face à l'agenda de
date dans l'agenda alors rapidement on
rappelle bien évidemment le forum de la
création d'entreprises donc il aura lieu
mardi 28 mai de 9h30 à 17h30 au Théâtre
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et puis la
11e édition du concours creac est lancé
il s'agit donc encore une fois
d'encourager la création d'entreprise
tant qu'on courir régional et national
ouvert à ceux qui ont un projet
d'entreprise ou aux jeunes entreprises
immat ulées depuis moins de 6 mois on
peut obtenir donc un chèque jusqu'à 5000